- We are both from Texas.
- I know.
- You're from San Antonio.
- Yay!
- Do you miss it?
- I do.
- I miss the Tex-Mex. That's what I miss.
- I miss the Tex-Mex. I miss the Tex-Mex.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I'm moving home. I'm
moving back to San Antonio.
- Oh, you are?
- [Eva] Yeah.
- Oh, I love San Antonio.
- [Eva] Yeah. But you're from Fort Worth?
- I'm from Fort Worth.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You're from the north.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I'm from the south.
- It is different.
- But I love San Antonio.
It's a great city.
They did such a great job.
Like just, it's an easy
city to walk around.
Like I don't see a lot of places in Texas,
it's a driving place, okay.
Like, but in San Antonio, I
feel like I can walk everywhere.
It's like Austin.
- You can walk a lot of places.
It's also, I mean, the best
Tex- Mex is in San Antonio,
and south.
- Or in Fort Worth, whatever.
- No, no.
I dunno, Kelly.
- Even he's like, "No." And, he's Texan.
- Thank you.
I'm a Texican, so I know.
- "I'm a Texican."
(both laugh)
I love it.
I just love the runny queso.
That's what people don't get.
It's the melted queso.
The melted cheese versus the runny queso.
- Yeah.
- I have no time for any
queso that's not runny.
- I know. A lot of cheese in Tex-Mex.
Because now I live part-time
in Mexico City, now.
- Oh, I love Mexico, as well.
- Mexico City.
And, the food is obviously
very different.
And my husband's Mexican.
And I'm Texican.
And so we fight all the time.
Like, he's like, "That's so much cheese."
- I'm like, "Yes."
- Exactly.
- Join me, won't you?
(both laugh)
It's like, it's so good.
- Hence the reason it's so good.
- No, I do like authentic
Mexican food, too.
- Yeah
- Yeah. Yeah.
It's amazing the the
diversity in Mexico food.
- Yeah.
- So you're there often?
You're in Mexico often?
- Yeah. Like half the time.
We're half Mexico City, half Los Angeles.
- That's awesome.
- And now we're gonna be
Mexico City, San Antonio.